whether you are healthy and want to stay
that way or fighting an illness the drip
bar LV the sponsors of this next segment
have something for everyone's personal
Journey
hi my name is Nathan Atkins and I'm the
managing partner here for the drifar Las
Vegas my wife and I are the owners of
the drift bar
[Applause]
[Music]
so the drip bar Las Vegas is an IV
infusion therapy center what we do is we
help maximize the benefit of cellular
Health what that means is simply you
normally get your recommended daily
allowances we do maximized beneficial
allowances so cellular health is where
all your health begins and here at the
drip bar we provide IVs to keep you
healthy so vitamin effusion is very
important most people think you have to
be unhealthy to start with vitamin
Fusion it's actually the opposite you
take vitamin infusion to enhance your
health so what we do is we help you stay
proactively healthy that minimizes and
reduces your health risk hey Nathan good
to see you buddy how are you doing buddy
I am ready for my results yes we have
your results so the last time you were
here we did your vitamin D3 testing
right so we have your results back but
before we do that I wanted to kind of
show you around a little bit because as
you can see it's a full house I love it
okay what is she getting done right here
so over here this young lady was getting
the power pack when we talked about the
last time you were you're right power
packs that energy in the bag should get
in health and wellness but she also
wants that energy she wants to be able
to get through her meetings for the day
maybe she wants to go hike Mount
Charleston who knows but that's going to
give her she's ready to go ready to go
over here she's got she got the
restoration so the restoration is key
for those of us in the valley because
it's about hydration and a lot of folks
don't realize how dehydrated they are
here in the valley so it's very
important to get hydration hydration is
key plus we also have vitamins and
minerals that keep them well on food the
fluids are key and I love the kind of
the lounge chair atmosphere relaxation
getting an IV and what is she on Deck to
get so we've got another power pack on
Deck so power pack is the popular one
yeah I can see and what you guys said
what's the time machine when I heard
about that one so the time machine is
the one where people want to do the
hands of time being turned back they
want anti-aging they want to look
younger they want to feel younger they
want to stay healthy it does all of the
above that I like that one too okay
results how do I get them all right so
what we need to get with Daniel so if
Daniel come on over all right so
Daniel's gonna walk you through exactly
what your results were and the
recommendation hello JC my name is
Daniel I'm one of the registered nurses
here at the drip bar I wanted to go over
a couple of results with you pertaining
to your vitamin D level all right you
got them back this is it right here this
is it I feel like I need a drum roll or
something for my results how am I
looking good looking like your vitamin D
levels are a little on the low side
normal range is between 30 and 100. okay
now you're sitting at a smooth 21 points
oh I am on the low side and after my
vitamin D will this be done with an IV
uh no it's not going to be done with an
IV we're going to give you a
intramuscular shot typically it's a
gluteal shot and then um from there it
will be absorbed into your system all
right I'm game let's do it
no not not here oh private room in the
back private room it's probably better
for you guys all right I'll follow you
Daniel let's go
[Music]
private room for that thanks again to
the drip bar lV for sponsoring this
segment for more information call
702-846-0851 or visit
ivlasvegas.com and they have a great
special offer locals receive 25 off
their first IV infusion they also offer
50 off for military veterans First
Responders and also teachers Las Vegas
now I'll be right back